[Music]
I love berry picking growing up in
Alaska we used to go berry picking all
the time and one of the things that
really messed about not living there is
we don't get to do that in the fall but
since I moved to Virginia thanks to
Tommy I discovered the autumn olive bush
so when Tommy was like six months old I
took him fishing the little guy runs off
and I turned my back and he starts
chewing up all these red berries I freak
out and go does my kid about to get
poisoned and died so I look up and
figure out what he ate and what he ate
was autumn olives and this is an
invasive specie of plant here on the
East Coast there's these little red
berries with yellow spots on a very
distinct looking and they're kind of
tart but once they ripen up there
they're not too bad and they make
awesome jellies and jams and ever since
figuring out that they weren't going to
kill my child we come out and pick them
and make jellies and jams so these are
our autumn olives the berries grow right
along the stems and they have these
yellow dots all over them they're red
with yellow dots and you can see here
the tree has kind of these long smooth
leaves you grow all over in Virginia but
look at how they just go and they're so
easy to pick all right so here's after a
couple minutes of picking yeah moves
pretty quick
[Music]
this is the big baskets I buy at the
Korean supermarket that I use for fossil
hunting and I end up using these things
for a lot of different things though and
they work really great for berry-picking
and for washing the berries afterwards
all right so about 15 minutes of picking
from one bush
this is what we got yeah not too shabby
I mean they're really easy to pick take
a very long time to get that many
blueberries they grow in these clumps
you just make them so easy to pick there
we go just having an something big and
wide even like a trash can lid would
work really well something big and wide
just to catch the berries so one hand
you hold this and the other hand you
just kind of rip the berries off they
are in here they're just everywhere you
get on the underside of the bush and you
can just see them everywhere check it
out we've got wild persimmons here the
wild persimmons oh these I love
persimmons they're one of my favorite
fruits ever we used to eat these in
Japan they are so good not ripe yet
they're gonna turn bright yellow and you
really have to tie them just right
otherwise they're nasty but if you get
them just right they taste like syrup
and brown sugar all right so we had to
stop for the day cuz it got dark on us
but this is what we've picked for one
day so feels feels like four or five
pounds of berries big old batch but I'm
gonna get a bunch more and so I'm gonna
let these sit in the basket so some air
will circulate around them and they
won't rot on me
and picking out some of the bugs and
stems and we'll go out at the end
tomorrow okay if you want to find autumn
olives one of the places you always want
to look is on the edge of roads on the
edge of streams and on the edge of
meadows and it's always going to be on
the sunny side the spot with the most
Sun so right here right there boom
autumn olive bushes so long bike paths
roads streams that's where you find them
now for whatever reason some bushes have
tons and some bushes do not
this one's just got a few so you're not
gonna waste your time with that we we
want to get a lot of berries quick here
we go this is this one's loaded look at
this how thick these are holy mackerel
tons of them yeah we're gonna get a ton
here this is from about two to three
minutes of picking this bush is loaded
oh look at this bush is loaded - and
these ones I like these ones are juicier
yeah he's a good
oh you get something let's see oh look
at dad buddy you do good drop those in
the bucket
how you doing Nathan oh yeah you got
some good job buddy
oh look at this this is insane
these are good quality one Zoe
oh just got stung by a yellow jacket
seen a lot of yellow jackets in these
bushes okay so my little helper here
decided to start throwing berries on the
ground so he could squish them Oh
naughty Nathan Oh check that out we
picked a lot of berries not quite a full
five-gallon bucket full but darn close
we'll look at that that is a lot of
berries hold on a second I wonder how
much that weighs 27 pounds of berries 27
pounds we'd probably have 30 pounds if
it wasn't for all the ones you guys have
eaten them thrown
hello Li macro that is a lot of berries
guys we had a lot of cleaning to do now
we've got to clean them we've got little
bits of leaves and twigs and there's
these little tiny stems in there there's
a few rotten ones maybe even an aphid or
two so we've got to sort all that stuff
out from the good berry so we're gonna
do it with this water cooler over here
basically I'm gonna dump all the berries
in and knock on wood I should be able to
get all the bad stuff to float to the
top and the berries to sink to the
bottom I'm gonna dump it in there I tell
you get your feet wet there's a few
floaters in here but most of its leaves
stems everybody so watch out watch out
okay now what we do just take this yes
and skim it out yeah they're starting to
float up see I just kind of got it set
up like this the hose is kind of
agitating the berries gently stuff is
floating up to the surface and then
working its way down to the end of the
cooler and just kind of every once in a
while move the hose around to kind of
kick up some more leaves and debris yeah
let that sit for a while
alright let's take a speak do it looking
pretty good
gotcha
[Music]
out
now when you eat autumn all is raw one
of the things you notice is the meat is
pretty sweet but the skin has this weird
tart flavor to it and there's a big seed
in the middle so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna separate the skin and the
seed from the meat and the juice and we
are going to make the jelly out of the
good tasting meat and juice and we're
gonna separate them by squeezing them
through a cheesecloth or if you have a
food mill that will work too okay so
these two pots represent about half of
the berries we picked and you see this
one's boiled down is kind of soupy and
this one's a little bit stiffer this is
kind of the the spectrum of what
acceptable this is about as stiff as you
want it to be and this is about as soupy
as you want it to be anything in between
that's fine so we're going to take some
of this cheesecloth and we're going to
use it to separate the pits and the
stems and the skins from the juice
[Music]
have more of a slow and steady squeezing
rather than a really aggressive rough
squeezing basically skins and pits and
stems the flesh and juice of the berry
is actually quite sweet it's nice you
know the skins don't taste so great and
they're really kind of unpleasant flavor
and you can tell the difference at this
part I smell this this doesn't smell
very good
but if you smell the juice it smells
fabulous so you're really the separation
process is super important so I've done
about three-quarters of the berries that
we collected and I've got about two
gallons of juice there and probably
another half gallon on the table so I
better clean that up before my wife
finds out all right so I've got a pot of
boiling water starting and I'm gonna
take the empty jars I'm gonna put them
in there for about 15 minutes to kill
off any bacteria that might be in there
if there's even a little bit of bacteria
inside the jar when you put your food in
it can spoil it and get to sick so
sanitize the jar first
these are 1 quart jars so I'm gonna
measure out how much juice we have and
it's not exact so 111 and change lemon
juice is helpful in keeping stuff from
browning so it'll keep the color nice Oh
peas up poop I turned my back to go
check out my smoked salmon look at this
mess oh crap
look at this I'm gonna get a shot back
not enough pectin okay so the jellied is
syrup a little bit frustrating but that
is gonna make some wicked awesome syrup
now what I can do is I can empty unseal
the jars dump them back into a pot add a
lot more pectin and try it again Tommy
are you eating all the autumn olives
Stevie a little bit so that's one thing
to do or I could just leave it as syrup
and put this on some crepes and pancakes
drizzle it on ice cream very tasty for
that as well okay so after yesterday's
disaster I pulled myself together
emotionally and I'm ready to get back on
the horse so I've got the last of the
berries on a pot we're gonna boil them
up we're gonna nail the pectin this time
I'm gonna do it
all right I got the juice boiled let's
cool it down and then strain it off okay
so I I'm only doing two quarts right now
because I'm so terrified of screwing it
up I'm holding some in reserve so 1/4
cup sugar and put it in the bowl then
I'm going to do one box of sure fell
that sure gel the less or no sugar rat
the version I mix it in by the way it
comes with instructions and and I'm
gonna bring this up to a boil and once
it's up to a boil I'm gonna mix in the
sugar and the pectin and then I'm gonna
bring it back up to a boil and add the
rest of the sugar and let it boil for
one minute and then I'm gonna jar it now
we're gonna add the sure gel and the
sugar okay it's starting to boil again
so add the rest now that I've added the
remaining sugar I've gotta bring it back
up to a boil and let it boil for exactly
one minute
all right now gonna throw some lids on
this and hope it sets up three more jars
knock on wood this one will set up we'll
check that out got some autumn olive jam
and some fresh butter on a nice roll
let's go check that out here time you
want to bite yeah well I hope you guys
enjoyed this video and enjoyed watching
us make some autumn olive jelly if you
liked this video you'd like to see more
videos like it check out the outdoor
boys YouTube channel don't forget to
that's right